petit rajout des familles je vous
rappelle que je joue le 29 octobre à
paris et vous avez été un peu dingue à
91 % des places qui sont déjà réservés
je vous met à lire dans la description
si vous voulez venir
je pense que dans quelques jours il y en
a plus voilà merci vous êtes au top et
on va se marrer c'est vous vous souvenez
peut-être qu'il ya quasiment un an
c'est-à-dire en novembre de l'année
dernière vous avez parlé d'une l'énigme
pour trouver un trésor de 50000 euros
déjà le départ arif le plaisir et le
projet pour trouver ce trésor s'était de
résoudre onze énigmes qui sont elles
mêmes contenus dans un livre et le
trésor est enterrée quelque part en
france
et là franchement ça te donne envie de
sortir une pelle
j'avais soutenu ce projet dès le départ
c'est ce qu'on appelle un coup de pouce
je le rappelle mes vidéos coup de pouce
ce ne sont pas des partenariats sur
lequel j'ai un intérêt c'est juste un
coup de pouce pour un projet que je
trouve cool et bien le livre ça y est
elle est sorti aux éditions du trésor ça
c'est la version collector que j'ai
reçue pour avoir participé aux faits ça
c'est la version normale qu'on trouve en
librairie
alors je les ai contactés pour que vous
puissiez en gagner mais pour le gagner
nous vous avons concocté les éditions du
trésor et moi même une petite énigme des
familles et résoudre jarret disent qu'il
serait cool c'est qu'on fasse une énigme
sur les cinq sens et eux ils m'ont
répondu ouais ouais ouais par un
ordinateur les cinq sens bien joué mais
nous on va partir en fait bon on a bossé
et on a réussi à créer cette énigme la
règle du jeu est très simple il ya cinq
sens donc cinq énigmes la réponse à ces
cinq énigmes ça va vous donner une
question il faudra répondre à la
question pour être très précis il faudra
répondre à ça sur twitter mais je vous
explique tout ça dans la description
plutôt que de vous le racontait alors
les cinq sens tout le monde les connaît
on les apprend depuis tout petits à la
maternelle mais il ya d'autres sens
d'ailleurs dont on parle jamais comme le
sens de l'orientation comme le sens qui
permet aussi de savoir s'il fait chaud
ou s'il fait froid mais on va se
concentrer sur les cinq sens classique
la vue le goût l'ouïe l'odorat et le
toucher
alors pourquoi les cinq sens parce que
justement ils sont souvent intimement
lié avec les énigmes
ils ont un lien très fort avec les
messages secret où les messages codés
par exemple savez-vous ce qu'est la
sténographie non écoutez je vais vous le
dire je le perds de plus en plus mon
sarko la sténographie c'est l'art de
dissimuler un message de le cacher ça
vient du grec steganos qui veut dire
couvert ou couvrir et de graff qui veut
dire message pas du tout ça veut dire
écriture graf en grec et ça n'a rien à
voir avec la cryptographie qui elle est
plus l'art du secret puisqu'elle cherche
à rendre un message incompréhensible en
le modifiant ses différents on passe
donc au 5 et nîmes dont les 5
réponse je vous rappelle vont former une
question et la réponse à cette question
sera donc la réponse à l'énigme donc
toujours dans la sténographie et
puisqu'une image vaut mieux qu'un long
discours voici une application réelle
vous voyez en ce moment même un message
d'apparence complètement anodine
pourtant si vous regardez bien certaines
lettres sont légèrement différentes
ce qui une fois remise dans l'ordre
devraient en temps normal former un mot
ou avoir l'air de former un mot enfin
bref cherchez vous pouvez mettre pause
parce qu'on va passer tout de suite à la
suite et la suite c'est le toucher alors
c'est pas facile facile de vouloir faire
une énigme sur le toucher en vidéo sur
youtube
ben non moi je peux essayer de vous
toucher mais à part dégueulasse et ma
caméra je sais pas ce que je suis rien
faire là ou alors faudrait que tu te
frottes toi aussi contre l'écran en même
temps le corps humain est assez
incroyable parce que parfois pour
compenser la perte d'un sens le corps va
développer d'une manière parfois
incroyable là des autres sens c'est
pourquoi les non-voyants parfois une wii
ou un touché beaucoup plus développé que
nous l'image que vous êtes en train de
voir actuellement et l'énigme du toucher
avec cette façon un petit peu bizarre de
faire un ciel étoilé
mais attention c'est peut-être parce que
vous pensez et si je vous disais
justement pour vous aider que vous
feriez mieux de vous faire aider par un
non voyant qu'il n'arriverait plus
facilement que vous à résoudre l'énigme
du mois à l'interpréter encore une fois
je vous laisse faire pause le temps de
chercher je vous mettrai aussi ces
images en lien dans la description pour
que vous puissiez les imprimés si vous
et bien passons à la troisième c'est à
dire le dorat 1
est ce que c'est vrai que les que les
youtuber c'est l'afp avant de faire la
venue au faux c'est pas coprah et et
sapho en vidéo on va plutôt faire un
voyage dans l'univers des nez et des
grands noms de la parfumerie l'aîné sont
les personnes qui créent et les parfums
au tout départ on a inventé les parfums
pour camoufler pour dissimuler une odeur
mauvaises odeurs et en particulier les
gants et les éventails donc au tout
départ le métier de parfumeur était
plutôt associé aux métiers de ganthier
dans quelques instants je vais vous lire
un petit texte dans ce texte il va
falloir que vous retrouviez les villes
auxquelles je fais référence
vous devrez comprendre le chemin et
retenir les initiales des direction
empruntée par exemple n pour nord-est au
pour le sud ouest etc et vous obtiendrez
ainsi un mot de quatre lettres
parti de bourges ce me diriger vers
cette ville française aujourd'hui
considérée comme la capitale mondiale du
parfum pour y recueillir des extraits de
lavande de là je rejoignais cette ville
allemande où fut créé cette eau
admirable qui porte désormais son nom
je finis ce long voyage en allant souper
avec mon ami monsieur molinar et voilà
encore une fois vous retrouverez le
texte dans la description en liant avant
dernière énigme le goût encore une fois
inutile d'essayer de lécher votre écran
c'est pas terrible de tu peux essayer si
ça te fait qui fait vraiment je t'en
prie au final on vous a plutôt préparer
une bonne salade de l'être ça ressemble
un petit peu à une charade rien à voir
avec chara puisqu'on est sur une salade
mon premier est en tête de veau mon
deuxième mon troisième se mélangent pour
se boire le matin ou dans l'après midi
pour les anglais mon quatrième s'inspire
entre deux bouchées mon cinquième enfin
peut-être en neige
voilà encore de quoi vous stimuler et
maintenant passons à la cinquième et
dernière énigme
la cinquième et dernière énigme si vous
avez bien suivi c'est louis et vous
souvenez de ce qu'on s'est dit lors de
la première énigme sur la sténographie
l'art de cacher des messages dans des
images et b à une variante à ça on peut
très bien caché des messages dans des
éléments sonores vous avez perçu
forcément des sons tout au long de cette
vidéo il ya de fortes chances qu'ils
aient un sens et des codes secrets avec
des bruits très courts ou débrouille
très long j'en connais pas énormément
on arrive donc à 5 henning sur lesquels
vous allez trouver 5 mo ce qui va vous
donner une question à laquelle vous
allez devoir trouver une réponse
accessoirement les cinq mots sont dans
le désordre il faut quand même recréé la
question vous même je ferai le tirage au
sort sur twitter où d'ici une bonne
semaine je mettre un truc qui est dédié
à ça il faudra y répondre je vous
explique tout ça dans les descriptions
comme d'habitude penser à liker la vidéo
et surtout à vous abonner et puis je
vous donne rendez vous le 22
à 15 heures pour la prochaine vidéo où
je vais mentaliser quelqu'un ça va être
assez rigolo quelqu'un que vous
connaissez
mais surtout j'ai une très très très
très à l'énorme en fait j'ai un truc à
vous dire et ça je vous le dit dans la
vidéo de 22 à 15h bonne recherche gagner
les 50000 euros
ciao alors ça c'est bien que ce soit sur
votre téléphone votre tablette ou votre
ordinateur vous pouvez cliquer sur le
petit cercle la wii juste là avec mon
visage
et si ça se trouve il ya les 50000 euros
derrière ou un petit peu moi je dis il
vaut mieux cliquer quand même clique
c'est bien
[Musique]